[Music]
[Music]
except for every
[Music]
for every
[Music]
for every
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no reason
for every
[Music]
for every
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know back when I was in the Academy
we would follow every toast with a song
[Music]
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's so Slurpee so much slurping here in
my headphones uh today was a good
morning Michael this is what episode
four six we are we have ted nugent ted
nugent on the show today are you shocked
Oh correspond Mandy will be here and
we'll be talking about Joe Rogan Bernie
Sanders what else our oh oh oh our
exclusive called NBC yeah talk about the
chloroquine fish tank and they didn't
they didn't just welcome you open arms
no no they didn't it was more of a
blatant rejection pretty much normal
dikembe mutombo right to the face get
out of my house that's similar was it
which one is it yeah your your don't
worry this is the month of mud club
quarantine that's the hashtag mo clip
quarantine you enter the promo code
quarantine you will get $30 off that's
our biggest discounts because everyone
else is gone they're not in their
studios believe me oh no Skype call yeah
those couple we turn this on you don't
you
that's my impression of this guy better
Mike it's not very good you guys it was
pretty accurate and lot of credit calm
/schedule so you can see all the live
broadcast today we're gonna be taking a
lot of your chats so the chat is only
available on blaze TV because they do
not let us do
Lincoln described well they let us do
chat on YouTube but they don't pay
nothing
they don't pay nothing so no they pay
something yeah well come on stop what
are you trying to get all dramatical
nazi with me and right now look look
look quarterback Garrett and audio ed
you see this over there no what's wrong
getting audio so we're just gonna make
well screw me you guys should get your
crap together uh half-asian Larry bill
Richman here for the first time in the
morning all right so let's do you need
me to buy some time
before we go to the first story yeah we
started okay we restarted the stream on
the blade on the blade side we apologize
without any words but you know like I
literally thought like they're literally
gonna see if they should cut Gerald's
mic oh yeah it should have a button
right here for I was like didn't we have
a whole meeting about how you guys can
just cut his mic off anytime anytime you
want you've already been given the
authority to do so as well
and we've repurposed the COFF button
thanks to the Gerald button Oh also Jill
can't be bothered to bring his own
pajamas - I don't have you should know
so no I baseball here
Gerald refuses to bring pit well Gerald
will review the Jama thank you Bill
refuses to wear pajamas it'll be a theme
and then Gerald's like I don't have any
oh that's an unsolvable problem election
I was not present at the villas wear
pajamas but now I'm gonna go all-in and
I like the Venezuelan election it means
nothing because I am put on your smoking
jacket yes everyone staying safe no one
has any slight cough sticking up a bit
right now and they're talking at CNN
right now about sure enough more doom
and gloom by the way apparently they
don't they overestimated how many
hospital beds they were going today look
they've got two more right there they
have two more beds and you can expect
them to say of course they were planning
on hospital beds
however they were only sent cots do the
administration's lack of foresight now
what can you say about the cots there
dr. Sanjay Gupta well as a practicing
physician cots are definitively less
comfortable than Sirtis it's a real
shame it's a real shame that that Donald
Trump didn't have the foresight to take
proper precautions and ensure that every
American can have a Sleep Number over
there in the hospitals now they're
paying for it no pillow top on the condo
no no it was because that guy the my fit
pillow guy is too busy is my fit my
perfect pillow my mind pillow my
piercing my really appreciate I really
appreciate that my pillow guy is
changing over to masks absolutely I
appreciate that
yeah good for him that's American
ingenuity that's coming together but the
pillow really is terrible whereby the
pillow I'm telling you they're really
yeah people about what you think you
sold a bunch of pillows because they're
crappy I'm telling you the people who
have had a little it does happen across
the world but people like we're talking
about needing clinical trials and Queen
I want double-blind placebo-controlled
clinical trials on my pillow on my
perfect silhouette say comparing it
approved it the placebo would be any
pillows and pillow Bert brand until
there's one there's one that's called I
didn't well they're not very memory that
term not me not very memorable
indulgence is the name of the pillow I
think I got it Bed Bath and Beyond and
it's quite nice
I do feel quite indulgent we're gonna
get to the exclusive call with the NBC
member which by the way she wrote the
report so her name we didn't remove her
name the report are they they haven't
Jersey Shore on CNN right what is this
right now master we have abs here to
speak out against the president is the
only pastor left in the northern
hemisphere with mutton chops this guy
looks like he needs a g6 got the Amish
facial hair with the modern pastor yeah
the modern sort of Hitler Youth haircut
yeah as the old school beat cop mutton
chops man this guy's a melting pot of
amazing stories he's the guy he's like
he's like alright Jesus give us the drum
solo right during the praise and worship
that's the Josh in the background
somewhere
Rob Bell is hanging himself with
bedsheets because he isn't getting the
airtime that this guy is right now
I wrote a book I wrote a book about how
Christians are wrong about being
Christians okay so the first story I
want to get to this is just a perfect
example and yeah we'll be taking a lot
of your chat here today Joe Rogan caught
a lot of flack did you guys caught a lot
of flack for saying that and this is a
guy who endorsed Bernie Sanders by the
way and I was very very silly and I
don't know necessarily why he did it but
you know I know joy wouldn't see her
necessarily close friends but I said and
I think now he's seeing why because
liberals had a meltdown over these we
have these this clip the recent comments
that he made regarding Biden versus
Trump this is the real issue with the
Democratic Party they've essentially
made us all morons yeah with this Joe
Biden thing you really have who do we
need I mean
I need a vote for that guy I can't vote
for him I can't hide Joe Biden I know
this Robert Smith vote for Trump than
him I don't think he could handle
anything oh now I may be really clear
here Joe Rogan did not say he will vote
for Trump so his defense Joe Rogan I
know there's always a lot of caveat
thank you well I'm pro-gun but well I'm
this but well Donald Trump does this but
edges everything that he has to say and
it's kind of sad to live in that world
where you have to do it but I do want to
be clear because people are attacking
him for something he didn't say he
didn't say I will vote for Trump he said
I'd probably rather Trump than buy yeah
it really isn't all that extreme of a
statement when you consider that one of
them has extreme dementia and shows up
on stage like he drank a bucket of salt
water right before emerging from his
life he's just like an empty suit right
now he's just I don't know how anybody
could put him up for a candidate in any
election to vote for him a couple of
facts you really quickly uh with
Democrats Biden leads Sanders by 22
points and then when you look at Trump
and Biden neck-and-neck 55% of Trump
voters very enthusiastic Biden only 28%
and this is something that's important
to what we're saying hey I would rather
have Trump versus Biden sometimes it's
kind of tough when you have candidates
before they're in a general election
right it's kind of tough to know exactly
what will happen or commit you remember
back in the day they did that sort of
virtual fight with Muhammad Ali in Rocky
Marciano
they put in some metrics and saw who
would win and that was the basis for
what is it Rocky 19
I think there was 22 that's out really
close and they created Creed and I don't
know why I'm in the minority where I
think that crea is an awful film but not
it's like okay listen we're gonna take
rocky yeah and remove all the likeable
characters and iconic music can we make
it more black we can make it all black I
thought it was a ploy to make everyone
like the older Rocky's more drove back
40 unfortunately had the exact opposite
effect where it's like oh you know I
should go back and watch Ninja Turtles
to leave it there just let it be so um
but in this case we don't necessarily
have to look at a bunch of hypotheticals
with Donald Trump in Joe Biden because
the one thing that obviously right now I
just read an article it's the
coronavirus stupid mm-hmm a little title
you know because that's going to be the
determining factor in the election and
as much as people want to say that
Donald Trump has done a terrible job I
don't agree with that we know for a fact
that Joe Biden was against the travel
ban which Donald Trump pulled pretty
early on right now if it flops just this
last week and he said that you know what
we do we do need the China travel ban
Bernie still against it which doesn't
make a whole lot of sense
I really just whoa whoa what do you mean
is make sense Bernie's a communist
French what doesn't make sense about it
this is a time when people need to be
able to stick together who like each
other and nobody goes better together
than Chinese Communists and Bernie
that's true that's like peanut butter
and jelly which is really a hot
combination when you think about it
saltines they'll go great with this what
welches hmm
put it on there I have no idea it's
disgusting I like peanut butter honey
banana but the point here is that's not
really what's most important it is
remarkable to me that Bernie Sanders
before all this you know he talked about
how Americans shouldn't have to compete
against effectively slave labor in these
other countries and he was really kind
of a nationalist so on people like Joe
Rogan come out and say Bernie's been
consistent you can't catch them on
anything I go on a second I think a lot
of people will be surprised when they
see in the general maybe even 60% of
Bernie Sanders supporters go to Trump I
guarantee you it'll be closer to a 50-50
split than people think all of his
supporters are not going to go to bite
and just like they didn't go to Hillary
Clinton but
reason for that I think is that at one
point in time Bernie Sanders sort of
espoused this American protectionism
which I don't entirely agree with but it
was tinged with a little bit of America
first nationalism yeah I could see him
doing much better than a general than
Biden because think about it this way if
people are pissed off about the response
to coronavirus they're looking for
somebody who exudes confidence and
leadership yeah he's not putting
sentences together very well we're on TV
right now so no but he's gotta like
thoughts that 28% was the amount of time
that he's actually lucid and that wasn't
just when his people were supporting him
right so it's just it's it there's no
way he can stand up and say I'm the guy
to lead us through this challenge right
so of course you would vote okay I may
have to hold my nose but I'm gonna vote
for Trump right that's what you're
pretty much gonna see from other Dems
well you know and I don't know I mean
you probably just have to hold your nose
if you vote for Biden if you're there
the debate cuz he poops he all he knows
himself pathetic so my little known fact
he doesn't really sad when you throw
yourself and your beyond the point where
you know how to fold it depends properly
yeah this is what we need to be
converting our factories over to not in
92 pens they can also act like I'm sure
they could also act like respirator
masks he was walking with upside-down
diapers Joe don't use the used one not
again you know what I hope I really
don't and we have we have a traffic
report coming I presume but before that
you know what I really hope we don't see
with Joe Rogan I really hope we don't
see an apology here I really hope that
we don't see Joe Rogan walk this back
and as you know I've appeared on this
show so bias alert obviously I've worked
with him personally he's been on this
show that being said I do see a lot of
walking things back a little bit not
just Joe Rogan but people in positions
of power who host podcasts or who are
who are on air yeah regardless
regardless of their political leanings I
don't want to see that happen right now
in other words Joe Rogan said nothing
wrong he didn't say first off I wouldn't
be wrong if you said you know what here
we've got Biden I'm gonna vote for
Donald Trump that wouldn't have been
wrong but him saying you know what
Democrats have made morons out of all of
us I've endorsed Bernie Sanders and now
it's Trump and Bernie at this point I
would probably rather have Trump than
Bernie
than by sorry there is nothing
controversial about that and what I want
to see is Joe Rogan go more on the
offensive point
you know what you know what folks okay I
I have the biggest podcast known to man
almost everyone else that exists in my
orbit and you can go fornicate yourself
with a wire brush how about that you
know what yeah hey see I love it for him
just come out and like show his NRA card
and now you've converted me to a
Republican forever and I don't think
that'll ever help me become a Republican
but you know what I wouldn't be
surprised behind closed doors Joe Rogan
probably but votes for Donald Trump over
Joe Biden how does Joe Biden represent
not only middle America but how does Joe
Biden represent anyone in the
entertainment astray the Hollywood elite
anybody period who does he represent Joe
Biden I don't understand is it just old
people push-ups is it just the people
here who are buying gold listening to
Sanjay Gupta unseen and nude is Joe
Biden represent can someone let me know
is it maybe just this sort of amalgam of
people saying he's the only one who can
run he's the only one who can beat
Donald Trump and then people being
nervous about Bernie Sanders because he
is a far left socialist and so this is
just kind of what we ended up with
because it's his time sort of like
Hillary Clinton I just don't know how
they ended up here and remember everyone
was saying this in the show like he's
gonna be Joe Biden that's it I know it's
gonna be an old crazy white guy at one
point I said I think it'll be yeah I
think maybe it'll be but gig because
that's nothing needed to cry you know
the whole to be like a young thing and
instead we end up with the crazy old
white guy but a crazy old white guy who
makes Ron Paul look positively tepid
does I do like I do like his unerring
supporter push-ups right I mean guy
push-ups lady push-ups marine push-ups
push-up bras I mean he's owned up all of
them big fan of Hindu plans he doesn't
every 7-eleven you walk you guys it's
it's just it's just where where is he
right now
right everyone is asking that whether
you're on the left or the right people
physically or mentally because the two
could be very different place no it's
clear we're not trying to put them in
the same place we're just are they at
least put something forward to be a
leader and he's not he and its
conspicuous the conspicuous absence here
is something that even folks who want to
vote for him or vote Democrat are saying
holy crap holy crap dude is this really
our guy yeah it's just crazy to me the
outrage
we saw with with Joe Rogan over this
yeah yeah that is what's crazy it hold
on really quickly we do have to go we do
have a traffic report actually and we
know a lot of you have to deal with some
complications right now the lockdown
morning commute so it's time for a
traffic report with Thomas Finnegan
[Music]
mr. Finnegan are you there sir I am here
Steven great well thank you for being
here what can people expect this morning
on their way to work
well more about that later I was in the
hospital for a couple of days following
last week's incident the stray sock yeah
but I'm well on the road to recovery
okay well what does that mean well on
the road to recovery
well my foot is fine however I seem to
have developed a bit of a dry talk okay
traffic is about the same as last okay
is there anything of note that we should
know about as far as traffic right about
the same doesn't mean exactly the same
yeah it's exactly the same okay well
thank you very much this on the traffic
report with Thomas Finnegan
[Music]
all right I apologize jail before I went
to that completely useless phone call it
seems on this what were you about to say
I was about to say that you're right in
that somebody we're looking for a leader
right thank you I was actually talking
to Bill but you're right people are
looking for a leader to kind of step
forward in his absence is conspicuous
but every time they have tried to put
him out there it only makes things worse
for him like the last few interviews
he's done on TV have just been
progressively worse each time and so I
think that the strategy for them needs
to be just to stay out of the way and
see if Donald Trump will take it on the
chin for the rest of the response to
coronavirus and then come back when this
settles down because every time he goes
out I'm less confident in him being able
to do anything integrating Donald Trump
take it on the chin
Donald there that's their hope yeah
right they want him to take it on the
chin and be so knocked down from his
response no here's they know it's a bad
analogy you know why because Donald
Trump takes everything on the chin
doesn't that his greatest quality exec
he's the CEO Clamato taken on the chin
and he's standing there like Ray LaMotta
in the Sugar Ray Robinson everything
boys he never got me Doug you didn't get
me dad Jake Tapper okay you never got me
that's what it is yeah it's amazing
kinda like I would like to see a little
bit more from you know bobbing and
weaving like okay no I'm not prepared
you just say excuse me excuse me
that's very nasty that's right Oh boom
boom if you don't have demoralizing
that's really absolutely crazy this is
it's an analogy what is happening is if
when you hit somebody as hard as you
possibly can that's what truck they did
it with Russia they did it with
impeachment and now they're doing it
with coronavirus and his approval
ratings going up when you stand there
and you can watch this in certain boxing
matches right you can see it where you
hit someone as hard as humanly possible
and it's and they keep on walking you go
oh [ __ ]
cuz usually okay he slipped it may be
all right okay he was evasive Donald
Trump that's his bets his whole strategy
there take it on the chin and then
eventually give you one example
entrusted to see Trump second term
because the media is just run all of
their options out I don't know what
they're gonna do for them I wouldn't be
surprised if he whipped out his Swanson
and took a piss right on a Costas
forehead
guess what a pitchman hey I think he's
gonna be so did you see the when some
reporter was reading a Biden tweet so it
was like I don't know if you saw this
but Joe Biden just tweeted something
attacked you said he didn't tweet that
he has people he has people and he's got
and Joe Biden he's not watching right
now and let's be honest if he's watching
he doesn't understand I will say this
Joe Rogan something else that people
missed in that podcast he said something
else that I think is very telling Donald
Trump really hasn't aged much as
president when you carry the George W
Bush when you compare it to Barack Obama
so much I mean it could be because he he
tans and he dyes his hair but as far as
energy like he went in where people are
saying this is an old person who's
incompetent and right now they're still
just saying he's an old person who's
incompetent but then they trot out Joe
Biden or in Canada why and that's
something he's gotten flack for to just
objectively saying that Donald Trump
really hasn't aged all that much it is
kind of remarkable to me I didn't really
think about until Joe Rogan said I think
he's tweeting just as much he's out
there right now he's doing still a slice
he's always been yeah oh who is oh my
god why do we have
it's a q-tip across New York State more
than half an NYC by the way one other
thing I don't know if we have a source
for this to bring it up but we'll move
on to the NBC call or we can actually go
to chatting a little bit but um they're
counting every single death in New York
City in New York State that involves
Cova at all as a coronavirus death right
and that to me is really bothersome in
other words if someone has leukemia a
heart condition
pneumonia and then at the end of all
that they test positive for
coronaviruses being listed as a corona
death yeah some people I don't think
this is true there were rumors
circulating that even people who died
like in car accidents who test positive
for Co but are listed I don't believe
that's true I wasn't able to verify it I
know when to believe that it's not true
however the idea of a limp of
really listing one primary cause of
death even though there are severe
comorbidities that is not in line with
the standard and how we always measure
deaths across this country we don't do
that if someone has leukemia if someone
has severe cancer you know when they're
undergoing chemotherapy and then they
also happen to get influenza we don't
list that as influenza death yeah
they're not drawing a distinction
between dying of kovat and dying with
right that's that's the industry well
there's no there's no reason not to I
mean every everything that's geared
right north and there right now the
hysteria the resources etc everyone is
geared towards yeah it's one you get to
blame Trump the more the higher the
numbers are the better it gets to be and
and I don't think that that's everyone
right I'm not saying like that no
earners down there like switching them
all over but there but there are we have
to take these numbers with a grain of
salt to say how are we actually
interpreting and what are we gonna do
from a policy perspective as a result of
them and if every single person is like
well just go ahead and put what this guy
down to you know write about to die
anyways yeah what I want to know too is
if these people who had died who had all
these other things going on as well if
they had gotten the regular flu or if
they had gotten really anything yeah
that'd have been the tipping point with
anything or is it that you know cover 19
is so severe that it killed them you
know what I mean like I think it matters
how these people would have fared with
regular flu that would go around every
single year if they had other
complication yeah it is undeniable
though it's helpful to know that the you
have a better chance of getting on
chloroquine early on with the z-pak than
you do of not using it and praying for
the best with a respirator sorry had a
respirator ventilator and Donald Trump
so that people saying oh my gosh how
heartless does he know this is
unbelievable to me I don't think we've
ever seen a more anti science driven
media right now right when they're
talking now no one here in this room has
said chloroquine absolutely works we've
said that non clinical data that is
available both in vitro and in vivo and
then you look at the anecdotal evidence
is is is pretty positive at very point
and it should certainly be provided as
an option and now it is provided as an
emergency treatment from the FDA a
medical option yeah the other side of
the hour right now they're saying there
is no proof there's nothing definitive
no there is some there is quite a bit of
definitive proof by the way and you
can't have it both ways because they're
also right now they're talking about
shortages this is something I was seeing
on CNN this morning when they're saying
in the problem with this too is if we
stop pilot pee
people who need it who have lupus or
rheumatoid arthritis who've been taking
this for years won't have access to it
on a second you just said that it's a
very dangerous drug that we don't know
how it'll interact with friends here's
the thing you can say that you can make
the claim that it is not fully tested in
the way that a drug classically is when
it comes to phase 1 2 3 clinical trials
specifically in its efficacy against
coronavirus you can say that what you
cannot say is that this is an unsafe
drug that we're an uncharted territory
we have no idea how people will react
and by the way we can't have a shortage
because the hundreds of thousands of
people with lupus and rheumatoid
arthritis or millennia use it they need
access to that medicine which is it is
it dangerous this is a drug that's
completely untested or is it a drug that
has already been FDA approved has a
remarkable safety profile and has been
used for a litany of ailments for a long
time now and it delivers promise on this
one that isn't entirely verified pick
one this is why people don't believe
your [ __ ] right exactly well I think
Steven it depends on which way Trump
goes they'll go the opposite right they
would have been like this thing is out
there we use it for everything why can't
we try this Donald Trump's keeping it
from us right they have that ready to go
I guarantee I think all we need right
now is Trump to come out and say nope no
chloroquine nope nobody do anything with
it right we're not gonna do it and then
the Trump refuses to investigate
important new I mean it's it's absurd
yes when we talked about it Trump came
out and said I identify as a woman I'm
the first woman president both sides of
these arguments going like the Super
Bowl were like the losing team stuff
just gets sold over somewhere in China
like they've got all these like placards
for Donald Trump and all this stuff like
he's saying that chloroquine can't work
in a can and their brow we can't use
that we got to go the other one guys
hole is that you're about to say we're
just gonna say we have a chance I'm
Natalie here or she's thank you about
the Joe Rogan think so she says I don't
understand but what is the difference
between what Rogan is saying about Trump
over Biden versus all the Bernie bros
who did the same in 2016 so a lot of
folks in 2016 pivoted from Bernie to
Trump yeah and right is she saying
what's the difference between
and what's going on broken there's
nothing you know what you know I can
prove that that the system that happened
back then we got a lot of flack by the
way a lot of flack from those in the
conservative media from sort of legacy
outlets that people like at Fox News
people who might be working for some of
the major publications and and not
unwarranted they were saying why are you
focusing so much on Bernie Sanders it
seems like it's just because he's cannon
fodder for comedy well namely the fact
that this is primarily a comedy show I
won't lie and sir that isn't taken into
account but at that point everyone was
talking about Hillary Clinton right
we had the analytics on on YouTube
through Google and of course at lot of
credit camera we bloody alone realize us
we get many many many millions of people
who come in traffic atlatl credit
outcome potentially at that point going
into the election so we had all this
data we were saying hold on a second we
can see that a lot of people who are
searching who are Pro Bernie Sanders
actually are surprisingly turning up in
a lot of this Trump related content now
that Hillary Clinton is going to be the
candidate so we always focused on Bernie
Sanders back then because this is how
I've said it and I will repeat it again
Hillary Clinton was the coronation
Bernie Sanders was the movement
candidate and people who were involved
with a movement and a big part of that
movement was looking out for the
American middle class first and being
anti-establishment they didn't go to
Hillary Clinton Andros they either
didn't vote or I would say problem I
would wager that a significant amount of
them more than have even actually come
up in any kind of polling went to Donald
Trump this is the exact same thing
happening right now I think that they
are anticipating a voter turnout for Joe
Biden that is highly unlikely and I
think they'll be surprised
all right so speaking of the chloroquine
stuff we have to move on to this phone
call then we have ted nugent in about
ten minutes geez we are running late you
know what maybe the show is just gonna
go late today because who gives a rat's
ass so it's us morning last week you
guys remember that we revealed this the
chloroquine leader the ladies of tank
fish tank cleaner okay the lady who
drink fish today and said she drank her
husband most definitely drank fish tank
cleaner her husband died right and she
gave the interview go back and watch it
where she said we trip we took it
because we trusted Trump and don't
nobody else should ever do the same well
that we went through that was a story
you were told and there were some
publicly available information but the
media was not interested in it that she
was a prolific Dimmick
donar that she hated Donald Trump this
was well-documented and that she had
history of mental illness and violent
outbursts what was exclusive to us is
that we found the court case where she
was charged ultimately found not guilty
but charged with domestic assault and
there were several different occasions
where she wanted to divorce her husband
and said that she was angry all the time
so let's recap this this was a woman who
was sold as a pro Trump lady who died
taking fish tank cleaner with her
husband when in fact she hated Donald
Trump and she hated her husband so we
thought that this might be relevant to
the original reporters at NBC they
co-wrote this story and we called them
offering the evidence this lady is there
were there was Vaughn I can't remember
his name in the Erica Erica what was her
hospital bed words they co-wrote the
original article yes you can find it
really see if you search this and you go
back to the original article this is the
one that was shared like a virus be
across all other mainstream outlets so
we tried to go directly to the source
and see if the media wanted to do the
journalism that their journalistic jobs
typically entail sounds logical and my
half-asian Larry Villiers mr. let's play
the audio if we have it hi Erika Edwards
steven crowder calling how are you good
thank you so much I'm so sorry that I
missed your call um do you have a minute
well I'm calling because um I'm actually
writing a story here and I have some
some information from an anonymous
source that I want to keep anonymous and
I know that you guys over there
obviously discretion is pretty important
it's regarding the woman who drank the
fish tank cleaner the chloroquine which
I believe I was trying to find who wrote
it I believe you co-wrote it with Vaughn
Hilliard yeah where are you calling from
so right now I'm actually calling from
just so you know I said I'm calling from
from [ __ ] Ville I knew that was a bad
sign can I continue if you don't laugh
at [ __ ] ville yes yes I'm a freelancer
and in you know again I I know
I've done some an eight-millimeter and I
know it's important to keep her
obviously anonymous I mean I'm assuming
you you know the person in question who
you wrote about sorry I should ask that
first yeah okay
so he did write the story and you are
aware that it's a it's great so I wanted
to ask you this I've come upon some
information you're doing some digging
the story originally that was published
you know stated that she drank fish tank
cleaner and obviously sadly her husband
died and there's an interview that was
posted where she said she did it because
she saw it from a Trump press conference
correct yeah
okay and then she did say that she
trusted him and that no one should
should do the same I had the article up
right here
I wanted to know since you know were you
aware of the fact that she was a you
must be a prolific Democratic donor
berry did you you guys you know her name
and obviously it's public record most
people don't have a name because I
understand it's anonymous and rightfully
so
I didn't say her name but I know you
didn't say your name but I'm just saying
I know her name I was just confirming
that way I'm not letting the cat out of
the bag so you know the woman in
question and obviously you guys do do
great journalism there at NBC News so I
wanted to know if if you had discovered
if you came upon this information er can
confirm that she's a democratic donor
who gave to Hillary in 2016 and
repeatedly throughout her yeah I don't
know any I don't know anything that's
not even relevant to the story quite
frankly isn't it relevant because she
said that she did it because Trump told
her to and there are multiple sources
here that show she was violently anti
Trump as an activist for a long time so
it seems peculiar that she would all of
a sudden decide to take medical advice
from Donald Trump when she also gave to
pro science anti right-wing anti science
ideology as it stated here nonprofits
okay I mean is do you have a question
for me or I mean it sounds like it's
your story well I am asking if you knew
this when you posted his story because
it seemed like it would be pretty
relevant no
that someone went out there saying no
one should trust President Trump you I
think that you have a specific story
that you're trying to tell and that's
totally no see I think that you did I
think that either you didn't do your due
diligence also let me move on here are
you aware about the assault case with
her husband that she mentioned divorcing
her husband because this is a totally
separate instance here we're not talking
about politics but she openly wanted to
divorce her husband and we found the
court documents of her being charged
with assault against her husband who
died from drinking the fish tank cleaner
were you aware of that
I think that you have a story there that
you should go with that's not go let me
ask since you published the original
story would you be willing to correct
the story since this is relevant
information do you not see it as
relevant information that a woman who
went out saying she did something
because she was a supporter of Trump
when we know that she's not and she
could see her husband I have the
evidence I can send to you would that
would that be relevant would you like to
care I don't have a big news outlet
that's the thing I have this information
I have corroborated it 100% with
authorities I would love to get it to
you because I would love to see the
truth get out here because as we know as
journalists it's very much it's your
story you can take it I don't I don't
want the credit I just want to make sure
the truth is out there and I can send
you all of this evidence if you would I
think that you have a story to tell and
I wish you good luck I think you have
the truth to tell here and I would like
to provide it to you NBC News do you
understand that this is the definition
of fake news at this point I can provide
you evidence right now that she was by
the way should be noted we sent this
email I think we have a screen shot to
both her and the co-writer with
verification collaboration of the
evidence and no response maybe they're
working sounds to me like you have a
story to tell um sounds to me like you
have a retraction too right yeah that
was an interesting response I don't see
how drove into the story hold on a
second you ran a story where a lady this
is what's so remarkable to me you ran a
story where a lady a man died because
him and his wife trusted Donald Trump
and drank fish tank
Weiner turns out they don't like Donald
Trump at all and she hated her husband
yeah that's pretty relevant yeah that's
a well especially because it wasn't it
wasn't just an unbiased report of it it
was basically making it sound like this
was a trump supporter values right after
taking Trump Towers and able to it
already
first off by the way Donald Trump didn't
go out and not only did he not say drink
fish tank cleaner I think people use it
that's way more of an extreme example
Donald Trump didn't go out and say try
to get your hands on legitimate
chloroquine e illegally no Donald Trump
didn't go out and specify a dosage
Donald Trump said if you're in a
hospital and there's a pot and you're
not doing very well before a ventilator
ask your doctor what can you lose at
this point
totally fella particular it was an
absurd example I thought that it
wouldn't get any traction unfortunately
it did and it's blatantly false yeah you
know what it also plays into the to the
narrative that a lot of folks want to
say it's the same argument that Hillary
had when she called basket of deplorable
you know she's saying look to take this
entire group of people and look here's
another example of a trump supporter not
only trusting their fearless leader
while he makes you know quote-unquote
gives bad advice but also they are
idiots right right well when in reality
this woman who was actually pretty she
had it it looked good little two-for-one
going there she not only got rid of the
husband she didn't want to have in the
first place and she got to stick it I
didn't want to can we say that that
speculation killed her husband yeah sure
she is the Carol Carol man to look into
it yes call him from prison and see if
we can have you heard about the fish
tank cleaner lady he's like I know I
think surprise I you know and here's the
thing I don't know how that necessarily
works as far as some kind of an
investigation
separate from the separate from the news
side of it because this would be
something that would we have to would
someone have to report that to local
authorities it seems like it would be
more of a national kind of investigation
concerned that involves donations a
long-standing history with it well I
mean the donations aren't a crime no no
they're not a crime but in other words
it's something that involves national
elections where it's not like the
evidence presented isn't just well she
was she was horrible at the local
supermarkets like no she tried to
influence elections for a long time and
she hated her husband no I mean
influencing elections is literally what
everyone does whether they're trying
toward they don't typically off their
husband play with the crime the crime
itself is the crime itself right it's
the same reason why there's no like
y-you know there's just the significant
argument against having hate crimes it's
because the crime itself is the crime
right as opposed to necessarily the
reasons behind it in local authorities
though like access her how would one
report it when they have to report to
the local police department you can
report it to any of them and then
they'll sort it out amongst themselves
might be investigating it right now and
we're just not hearing about it well
we're definitely hearing about it as
long as erica has to be doing her job
well yes right I just can't imagine this
is the reason when people don't trust
the media this is exactly why like this
isn't an example of me I didn't we
didn't call it aggressively go on you
crazy you know like hey this is relevant
would you like this sounds to me like
you have a story sounds to me like you
had a story someone came in and said and
here's the crazy thing think about this
is it could there be anything more
catnip e to reporters than a salacious
story of a woman who potentially offed
her husband yes yes yes yes if Donald
Trump offed her husband and that is the
story they decided to run with the only
thing more appealing than Joe Tiger and
Carol Baskin or making a murderer is if
said murderer can be implicated as
president Trump I know and it seems like
unless the road leads back to trip to
Trump it's not a story but that's not
true at all like this would be a major
story either way yeah if a woman like
off their husband by saying here drink
this it'll cure Cove in nineteen it's
like well that's a story they ran it
like it was Donald Trump as Kathy Bates
and Miss right exactly
take your caloric Li I do like how
Stephen says Joe tiger cuz everytime say
I start thinking you're saying Joe Biden
tiger and then I'm like oh wait Joe
exotic to exotic oh that's right
everything
are you talking about like it like by
the way gun to your head you have to
vote for Joe Biden as president or Joe
exotic jokes exotic yeah for sure much
as I don't like him that man get stuff
done to mail concubines who argue even
gay because of 20 Tigers is 20 Tigers
what using videos to come out of it I'm
not gay I'm not gay but 20 Tigers is 20
Tigers now you know who we need to find
we need to find the guys who wrote the
music there's some really good articles
about the guys who actually wrote in
reality was lip-synching he write one of
the guys I think his died that we read
that I think last one of the guys know
he was not he was not related to Tigers
at all yeah I am it is remarkable to me
because we've always had questions I
think is guys right okay what would it
take like for you to you know have
relations with a guy who's kind of like
10 million 20 million we always ask
these questions right to guys and
usually and we always I don't know I
don't know I haven't I usually ask it to
people but entry would be 20 Tigers out
of my pocket just means power anything
20 they say Barry are they sorry
bring in the Train snow leopards no I
don't get it no that's a move that takes
place once it's big I don't want to hear
about that so what do we have we have
them on the line yes we do all right we
live on the line right now none other
than the great mr. Ted Nugent mr. Ted
Nugent how are you sir I'm doing so good
at stupid in spite of the crazy world
around us how are you and your family
out there Stephen we're doing well and
you know I thought it was perfectly
appropriate here mister you've been in
this in this very studio a couple of
times but actually think before it was
before there was a garage yeah you've
been still permeating the brick where
and just isn't that can you still smell
my essence of truth logic and common
sense still promoters yeah we do it
smell it smells like a deer covering
scent and tapioca pudding because I know
you like your snack packs and so that's
a little tidbit most people don't know
about that would be tinks number 69
no morning now I don't want to reveal a
location
but obviously you split your time
between Texas and Michigan your proud
Texan proud Michigander where are you
quarantine right now if we can
quarantine and our beloved home or
there's freedom and a hint of
constitutionality right here in Central
Texas Texas we don't just live in China
spring and Shimane hates when I mention
that but you can google where we live
and if somebody wants to mess with us
I'll send you my itinerary we don't only
live in China spring we own the spring
that China Spring was named after hence
the most important element of having
uncle Ted on your show Stephen yeah is
that unpacked locked already rocked the
Glock dock I have always had unlimited
water unlimited fish in the water
ah unlimited firewood in case the power
goes out but case the power goes out
I've always had a generator with fuel
for at least six months call me weird
but I figured that out about 1967 after
a Michigan ice storm I'm like a boy
scout
eat me well I don't think you want to
say like yeah boys again especially with
the counselors who are a lot in there
that's the news that's the new slogan at
the Boy Scouts by the way the new
counselors is distance Shh all right
this is live so we apologize no you know
this is interesting you bring it up
because I used to do this where I talked
about as being of the ice storm you know
Montreal many people died from the
Montreal ice storm I don't know if you
remember that but we actually had
relatives Duke's played during an
absolute blizzard whiteout everything
was shut down but the Amboy dudes me
driving the van we actually made it to
Quebec and Montreal for a concert but
we're we are right there through the
blizzard just in time to go on stage so
everybody had already left because
everybody was scared the blizzard yeah
I'm from right there from Canada they
should have been better prepared you
think they should have been better
prepared but no they were not it was it
was terrible and when we used to do this
I don't think their sponsor anymore but
prepare with Crowder it's just kind of
like you know uh emergencies and
supplies and I always said when I would
do these advertisements listen there
doesn't have to be some crazy EMT attack
it doesn't have to be some crazy
post-apocalyptic scenario it could just
be like earthquakes that you have in Los
Angeles which my brother had lived to it
could be like the ice storm where all of
a sudden the stores are picked clean it
pays to have a supply of water
and some food that can last you 30 days
people said it was crazy I guess with
this you're you're a little crazier
because six months you have you have you
could live for six months completely off
the grid well I Got News for you without
exaggerating I could live forever
oh yeah cuz you're a bow hunter but I
mean you know I mean how many how many
deer do you need you know we have so
much wildlife on the property literally
when I graduated from high school in 67
I was already prepped I was raised in a
hunting family where we had to gather
wood at the camp you had to gather water
you had a start your fire you got to
kill a squirrel for dinner I mean you
know basic utilitarian pragmatism
self-sufficiency utilitarian pragmatism
self-sufficiency is that legal and
entirely sure if you care of yourself I
was taught all about that so by the time
I graduated from high school even though
I was a crazy rock-and-roll mushy brain
uneducated by the American anti
education system guy I had the basics
figured out so my first purchase in life
was a little farm in Michigan where I
had unlimited water unlimited fish
unlimited wait a second hold on said
that was your first purchase you never
put like a quarter in the little little
rooster egg machine to get yourself one
of those sticky hands huh your first
purchase was farmland I'm calling I'm
calling BS absolutely you never bought a
stick of Bazooka Joe that was my first
personal purchase I had to buy a van for
the Amboy Dukes we had it I had to buy
amplifiers to the employ you Tom was my
musical dream obviously which I achieved
I must say by the time I was 12 or 13 in
Detroit little Eve won the Battle of the
Bands in 1963 opened up for The Supremes
and the Beau Brummel's right next to the
mighty Funk Brothers of Motown so my
American Dream was on fire really early
on but my again it goes back to my
hunting fishing trapping conservation
lifestyle right I've just never been
unprepared I've never been unarmed I've
never not had a pocketknife I've never
not had a handkerchief I've never not
had a fire extinguisher I've never not
had a spare tire just the basic weighs
like a knife handkerchiefs
the only non explosive item but I
imagine deadly it's true today come on
come on yeah yeah and I shouldn't be
surprised at the color by the way as far
as as far as the camo Ted we can still
see you the bookcase it doesn't
necessarily blend let me ask you this
because we don't have a ton of time this
one we've gone over time what would you
recommend to people out there who aren't
sort of conservationists like yourself
we don't live this lifestyle
what do you like this what are the basic
fundamentals that everyone should have
well a handkerchief for starters okay
I'm right there with you lives I've
literally stopped bleeding saved lives
with my neckerchiefs God but anyhow you
know isn't it a shame that you have to
reference the author of Wango Tango for
survival stuff but but there are some
basics and first of all prayer we're
praying for those people who are maybe
not on the edge of self-sufficiency and
not living the original last Boy Scout
preparedness I think that's what ansible
human being should be but we're not we
haven't bought any toilet paper I mean
again I'm going back to ice storms in my
youth and in blizzards and floods and
droughts and hurricanes and tornadoes I
mean who hasn't lived through those so
we all have a few hundred rolls of
toilet paper I swear to god we have a a
reasonable pantry we have long lasting
canned goods of quality but we have
unlimited fish fowl venison because we
live on land that provides life itself
yeah but you have to have you have to
have food water toilet paper you have to
have guns ammo you have to be adequately
trained you have to have fire
extinguishers you have to have adequate
fuel I've always been trained that you
fill your gas tank up in your truck or
your car at the end of a trip into town
even if even if the gas gauge has only
gone down a little bit than you just
because you're front of Detroit and they
invented carjacking there's a there's a
drive-in movie theater still in downtown
Detroit it's the stuff that gives childs
it gives children nightmares
you drive past it in the downtown at
your own time
in town Detroit it's right next to an
overpass like a drive-in movie you're
going I'm gonna I'm gonna start watching
you know big trouble too and my car is
gonna be nothing but cinder blocks in a
steering wheel before we get to the
double feature all right my theater
oh yes yes exactly it's a drive by don't
wear red don't wear blue just stay
neutral mr. Nugent we do have to get
going we have our Jocko correspondent on
here where's the best place for people
to find you brother well go to Jerry
Garcia Garcia calm for all the things
Ted Nugent Ted Nugent calm website and I
don't know if you're a pg-13 but I'm
selling the hell out of those things
GABA we have real ultimate high-octane
yo social man in our teen here but we're
quarantined in between tours and a verse
as a competitor there but I will say
this it is remarkable that Jerry Garcia
so annoying but unfortunately it
unilaterally agreed upon
there's the pun with Jerry Garcia is the
best ice cream available it's absolute
it's so delicious and I make a little
root beer floats with it and I mash it
let's see I support those hippies I love
the hippie ice cream oh right okay Thank
You mr. Nugent we appreciate it brother
we must go before we thank you God bless
you and God bless america you can you
can hang up there because we don't know
what he's going to say and I can't watch
until yond that when Ted Nugent was on
I'm sorry it's not yo-yo ma with the
cello hey yo yo mom moves me man what am
I saying
where's the Cherry Garcia now I'm hungry
that man is an absolute treasure okay we
are going ever gonna go to some of your
chat we are going to have our Jocko
willing because Jocko will Inc is
actually a lot of people have been
wondering how he's doing we actually
smooth Manny our Jocko willing
correspondent who will be happier after
the break and we'll also be talking
about voter suppression and louis c.k so
short break we'll be right back after
this hey hey guys so we got an idea a
bright idea
laying on with a commercial for black
rifle coffee company we will show
everybody how good the coffee is but
beating your black
yeah don't be so good you're gonna
forget we just beat your ass
I started off wait come on hook up the
brains of that ideal yeah go home come
on man you could be the hero I'm a whole
you all's back what if he punches you in
the stomach
no I'm afraid no I don't think any of
this is necessary son it's not gonna sit
like a wooden trestle well we can we can
run it by Stephen but I don't think he's
gonna be into it okay yes sure trust me
he's right dad it's glass yeah go ask
them hey guys
whistle blower 22 here sorry about the
gap between videos I got kicked out
again but I promise this new scoop will
be the biggest of my career to be honest
once I exposed this I fear for my life
it's time for the truth eight footage is
not gay the story never added up not
coming out until 30s recoiling from any
physical intimacy with his alleged
husband the deep state has gone to great
lengths to cover up and rewrite mayor
Pete's history because not only is he
not gay
people to judge is a plant he's been
handpicked by vice president Mike Pence
to run for president and then once
installed in the White House he'll sign
an executive order to create Pence's gay
conversion camps it's been Pence's plan
all along and when President Trump
didn't agree hence went with Plan B plan
footage thanks for watching and ons I'm
gonna shout out everyone who contributes
when I go fund me starting with mr.
Patrick s so yeah guys thanks for the
support and we good Club which by the
way one of the funniest funniest hours
available right now on you listen to the
Artie Lange a halfway house not free oh
my god it was a treat if you guys are
looking for a laugh I hope we could
already laying back on this show I don't
think I'm one in the back last time he
was on the show he was doing drugs
literally right before the show almost
almost on the show and he's very open
about it now he's finally sober Artie
Lange good yes he was on the show and
because we could literally hear him
we thought we suspected I should say
doing drugs and he made some
that's where he seemed kind of out of it
yeah there are only two interviews that
we've ever actually edited yeah people
say Oh sometimes I have to pre tape it
because of timing one won't get the name
because it's a very nice person what was
incredibly boring and ya couldn't
actually get them to stop so yeah it was
inconsequential one was was Artie Lange
because we felt that he wasn't in his
right mind and we didn't want to be a
liability for him yes what would really
love to have him back on fun he was such
he's such a sweet guy yeah but his hour
with Gilbert Godfrey right now is so
funny they were talking about I'll just
repeat this for you a little bit you
were telling how Robin Williams did
Gilbert that you know there's a 3-1 on
the Robert Williams Robin Williams
actually killed himself because of how
good your life is you know and if I
would love to go back and I'd love to go
back to 99 people watching Aladdin
saying yeah one of these guys is
actually going to have an incredibly
successful career and one of them is
going to hang himself with the ladies
piece of clothing making Anna news no
news just says offensive things and
laughs that's all it's not even a
jealous I don't know that you can teach
it where's this where's this party
halfway house parties a new show and
there's something certain people you get
them in a room with him and Gilbert
Godfrey the chemistry is just electric
so we before we go to our course when I
want to talk about louis c.k after that
before we talk about voter suppression
but right now of course many of your
incident of the show he's on quite a bit
and he's disappeared a little bit so we
want to make sure that he's okay so
there is no man more up-to-date on the
goings-on of chuckling it's time for our
Jocko correspondent
[Music]
and in here smooth mani come on in here
let's come on in Jocko correspond very
much audio way you get some questions
smooth you are of course you're from
Columbia yes correct and you know more
about chocolate than I think anybody
ever perhaps would you said yeah except
choco yeah of course well yeah I
appreciate I appreciate you giving
credit where to do want to run the risk
of ever not you can't can you fill us in
so first off we have all you have all
these things right correct so and to be
clear origin main that's the face mess
can you bring it up real quickly
that's Jacko's company and thank you
guys they did send some out to us where
there's there's a little pocket in there
to where you can put a surgical mask or
some other kind of a filter and they've
repurposed all of their all of their
factory to do that and then all of this
though when they sent that they sent us
some samples like of the protein powders
and you said you've had all you really
I've had all of it that one's good that
one's good that one's better that T's
better so what is going on with with
Jocko these last couple weeks you know I
think the questions Steven is what isn't
going on with joggled you got your
nutrition your goods if you want to read
you've got children's books yeah you
have durable goods d you know we've just
we've got the masks re innovated the
mass mm-hmm and I hear the CDC actually
thinks these might even be better that's
wrong I don't want to be really really
clear about that what have you been
doing to keep up with with Jacko during
all this actually I think we can go to
his Twitter you know can we we can check
that he has indeed been waking up at
4:30 for of course really okay in the
morning that's correct okay he's getting
after it he's getting him before the
enemy correct it takes an Instagram
photo then goes back to sleep until noon
I think so from what I understand photo
he uses ever he doesn't find this funny
at all zero funnies
this is loaded okay all right
Jaakko say about having a loaded firearm
and ended up to see a mate at the CNN
monitor no one ever thought yeah over
that who would trigger discipline okay
and either way this my everyday carry
and where did you learn your good
trigger discipline obviously chuckle
right that makes sense
did you have some questions from there
audio yeah I mean I did hear that Jocko
has fallen off with the 4:33 thing but
we let's see so he has we do have the
most current aftermath of his workout so
he I never mind so body workout okay and
what do you what do you say what do you
think is helping Jacko right now most
getting through the ab the corona virus
pandemic because we all sort of we cope
differently how do you think Jacko's
well besides creating this mask that
pretty sure the Surgeon General of
America is more potent no vaccine for
max aren't potent but he is there's not
a vaccine yet right are you putting
venom in your mask you know it's not
like bein in real life like if you put a
potent venom in your mouth so what else
to say is it do you think
jakka what do you think is this big
biggest qualit a what is this I'm sorry
I can hear your question because my
Jacko go has been opened and this might
also be a cure for this is terrible you
know what I almost feel like we was
going on with Jocko and it's a deal
under the table there might be Joe and
I'll tell you what we're gonna have you
back next week or maybe not maybe the
week after and we'll check in and and
bring us something more substantial next
time than just Hawking Jacko's Goods how
is that drink by the way it's delicious
well I don't want to try it because
you've been wearing your poison man oh
yeah I'm pretty sure that all this is
publicly available information I don't
know if there's any kind of inside yes
that's right do you have any insight in
for me anything that maybe people don't
already know these are just my two cents
but you're correct this is all public
knowledge okay I think if he's gonna
come back on the show he needs to take a
photo of himself at 4:33 every morning
yes yes otherwise he's not really a true
correspondent so we need a base yeah in
black and white yep black and white are
you way ahead of you newspaper check my
Instagram
thank you very much smooth mani enjoy
your drink because I don't want to get
Corona that has been our wildly
unproductive installment of Jaco
correspondent
[Music]
okay so I wanted to ask you guys really
quickly do we have were we able to pull
that video from that awful female
comedian before she removed it on
Twitter
Louis hell yeah Gerald's not awful I
don't know if we have it right now but
we can put weekend or but well cuz she
blocked me and deleted it so CK was
trending yesterday because someone
released another special and of course
all these people come out from the
woodwork to say I can't believe that he
would release a special and there's one
female comedian who keeps complaining
about louis c.k saying anyone who
actually pays for a Louie CK special
stop talking with me because effect
effectively implying that people are
rapists and sure I'll put her this awful
awful sketch let me know if and when
just give me a hands up of a parody of
the Louie intro and it was just saying
you know Jay King yanking jacking off
that was the only lyric change-o and it
was so bad it was so poorly edited I'm
like listen even if let's assume that
you believe louis c.k is a rapist on par
with roman polanski who got multiple
Oscar nominations and Oscar Awards after
it and a ma fourteen-year-old on slay
lose at least Louie CK asked it's weird
it's weird it's a weird request it is
but he Pitt makes the request also not
kids right you know so not [ __ ] let's be
really really good but let's assume that
you believe he's that terrible don't you
understand that creating something so
painfully unfunny just drives people
into the arms of louis c.k you're
hurting your own you're creating more
louis c.k fans hey she's a deep state
louis c.k fan busted it way open didn't
see there's disgusting I know we
actually do have the okay so what's the
name of this lady so she deleted and she
blocked me she deleted Twitter yeah yes
and this was one all of these complaints
about louis c.k saying he's not he's
horrible he's a rapist he's only made
advancements in his career because of
white men let's assume that all of that
is true okay let's see uh what's her
name Kelsey Caine Kelsey Caine what do
you got
[Music]
why the only reason have to run all of
this is because it doesn't go anywhere
you need to seal boy that this continues
wait is that not louis c.k so everything
is the credit involves penis which I can
appreciate look at this - she keeps she
cut she breaks character and they keep
it going
everything about that and not that I
can't be low-budget and satisfactory
this is low budget low budget and
distinctly unsatisfactory look at this
look at this she's trying to go so yeah
at the end of the clip she tries to go
into the Comedy Cellar because that's
where Louie often goes and they don't
let her in look they they don't even cut
it early enough it's just so painfully
bad and unfunny that here's the thing
funny doesn't lie and that's kind of a
difference between let's even say take
Roman Polanski or however Weinstein
people who are actual sex offenders
right now there are a lot of people
involved with those productions there
are a lot of people involved with the
creating of a film where they can't
really take credit or necessarily take
blame if for example like Lions for
lambs is that bad but funny doesn't lie
and louis c.k I guess the question
becomes when is someone paid their
penance if they were granted did some
scummy stuff and I understand that it's
not just that he was servicing himself
in a green room I understand that he
asked people maybe there was people felt
pressured and obviously there could be
sort of a disproportionate abuse of
power there or Authority yeah but again
it's like the guy did apologize the guy
went away and he's not saying that I
should be out there as a role model it's
just is he still funny and the answer in
my opinion is undoubtedly yes so what do
you what do you think at what point do
you it's tough to say but don't we do
this all the time anyway we separate the
art from the artists with people that
maybe we just have a mild disagreement
with them or they write batshit crazy
like Tom Cruise and Scientology and
we're like huh you know people still go
watch his movies I'm not saying they're
good or bad I'm just saying people still
do it and in a case like this like that
is they are better but in a case like
Mission Impossible or or Tom Cruise and
Henry Cavill were both fighting the
death Asian guy wasn't zero progress
until the woman comes interesting
I failed due to 20 of Cavill on decadron
might have had no all of a sudden you
120 pounds soaking wet and stilettos
move the needle especially when he
reloaded his fists wait I thought it was
over
Tom Cruise was wearing stilettos they
need you on set can you please take off
the stilettos and put the nine inch
lifts on this we're not supposed to
scene it out so you're saying separate
the art from the artist so you're a
Roman Polanski fan oh no no no I'm not
so look I think I think it gets
difficult very much so when you have
stuff like this happen right this is
this is different and I think some
people will have an opinion and say look
I'll just never watch that guy again on
everything right well I still think so
here's a comparison and I hate what Bill
Cosby did but I go back and I look at
his Bill Cosby as himself stand up like
that was hilarious it doesn't change the
fact that what he said at the time was
funny I don't really know cause we
talked about chocolate cake for
breakfast louis ck's stand up is about
being a horrible person it was anybody
who had seen anything he had done
actually surprised I don't think so no
no I really don't think so yeah words
you know Bill Cosby was out there and
then he was raping 419 people yes
numbers are accurate I think it's about
the equivalent to the entire Lakers
roster history something they came for
yeah yeah there are no women on the
Lakers roster right well you are with
the WNBA okay this is this is a genuine
and then I want you to go genuine
question what is the name that when
people say I love women's sports and
some people in this room have done it
but not so much what's the name of the
Los Angeles WNBA team go can anyone give
it to me
not even close mystics know the film
with Julia Roberts and a pizza party
it's the Dragons
please there's no way the Dragons what
other zodiac symbol can I say is most
comparable to cancer so research has
found that it is the sparks from Dark
Crystal
WNBA they're just not from LA yeah I
heard you know what no not only I don't
really loved our crystal that much but I
guarantee you that if you just had you
know like movies in the park they do
that sometimes I have movies in the
parking in the park
you had the WNBA National Championship
and the making of documentary of Dark
Crystal
everyone would turn their chili built
the whole village without Jim Hansen
they're still getting its are cool this
is an experiment that needs to happen
turn to the NBA right WNBA because they
assume that the hairdo is a puppet show
well they thought somebody believed that
did not a we which will undoubtedly be
torn off I almost got fired by the way I
hit the notification bell please if
you're watching on the YouTube because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot and
please do consider joining up Mudd Club
we're doing this extra content free all
month because of mukluks quarantine
entering the promo code quarantine you
get $30 off and please if you are a
member of Mudd Club do consider renewing
because we need you still around
sincerely monetize to wrap up the louis
c.k think i don't like what he did no
but i think the guy's funny and i don't
think it's such an unforgiveness in that
is so unforgivable that the guy can't go
out and tell jokes that people want to
pay him for it yeah right yeah and i
mean at what point do we allow somebody
to be truly repentant like do it I mean
are you done Everywhere's the line like
are you done for the rest of your life
like can you ever
say you know what I was a horrible
person then I'm not that person anymore
is there any repentance is there any
second chance that we give anybody right
or do we just you know put somebody in
the corner and say well because of what
you did now I don't know where that line
is hurry but because of what you did
we're never allowing you to be in
society again no no it only applies to
him because he's a white male pretty
much he's Latino he's Latino he's more
Mexican than Carlos Mencia Carlos Mencia
yeah but Luisa K was Hispanic Honduran
is Hispanic and he wasn't Mexican at all
Louie CK was late he's not Mexican at
all
no no Karl zeros not Mexican all he's
half Honduran he's like polish or
something his real name is Ned hey you
mean if I went by Beto and my name is
Robert understand I will now go buy some
Asian name exactly it's Mexican is
Patrice O'Neal I think louis c.k was
actually raised in mexico if I'm not
mistaken I think he was uh I don't know
it was born in Mexico City no it was
actually raised in Mexico City doesn't
really advertise it but almost hides it
the reason the real thing is I was just
being persnickety and I wanted to
correct my lawyer for no reasons because
it's not really relevant the perception
is he's a white male that being said for
me there's no line for me there's no
line as far as is it still funny
well I doesn't now that there is a line
and since that someone doesn't get to
work in the industry anymore for example
Roman Polanski rape of 14 year old with
quaaludes I don't get it should be
allowed to work anywhere as with will or
without the quaaludes is the qualified
unfairly one could almost be a ludes
were really the only saving grace of the
event
what else you got going oh no that's the
argument that could be mayor of a quail
it were not the worst part of that
equation now they would not know some
what are you necessary so I do think
that he shouldn't be allowed anywhere
children right and probably don't send
any women into the green room with louis
c.k unless they like watching redhead
mexican service themselves like but
point is he's not a danger to anyone he
didn't commit a crime
and it's not like the Harvey Weinstein
situation sorry I don't think we can
lump even as much as I can't stand Aziz
Ansari I really think this guy isn't the
the epitome of woke and dishonest and a
little bit arrogant he had a really bad
date yeah yeah we can't lump that in
with Harvey Weinstein and Bill Cosby and
it's just amazing to me that I do notice
what the comedian's particularly you
would think that if someone is a real
germ right and they talk about the the
sort of hierarchy of powers-that-be
well other people in positions of power
who don't need bill who don't need louis
c.k would be the ones who would speak
out and say he's a real journalist guy
needs to go away but you don't see that
from the bill birth of the world you
don't see that from the jim Norns you
don't see that from comedians who stand
nothing to gain by being subservient to
louis c.k in other words they could go
out and say that and guess what they
could actually eliminate competition
yeah but all ones that you know what no
the guy is still funny the people who
come out and say louis c.k isn't funny
at all therefore you should all boycott
them are women like this are people who
are definitively unfunny and they argue
well that's just because of the powers
that be you know the powers that be
think the guy is funny and they have no
reason to assuming that jerry
bruckheimer is you know if anyone had
dirt on Harvey Weinstein you'd have
someone like a brookheimer someone who's
this direct competitor it would be the
easiest thing in the world yeah I mean I
think about it this way with sports like
we're selectively outraged and you have
athletes to go out and do things that we
disagree with but they go out and still
they are able to perform athletically
and so we allow them we're like oh well
pay well go watch the basketball team
that has three felons on it right now
because they can score right so they're
selectively kind of picking their spots
and where they're gonna be outraged in
against - I don't know anything about
basketball I just you should you should
there's a lot of felonies one more white
guy go that's nice and that's an almost
all organized know in a lot of sports
especially in combat sports and physical
sports because this is the way
for a lot of people from rough areas in
town and I'm saying that if you were
raised in the lap of luxury you often
you know you go play tennis or golf
right there's a there's there's felons
on basketball teams and football teams
in in wineries and not in winery cellars
wait no oh yeah
distributors yeah you don't think
Polanski made a couple of visits to
copal as vineyard come on don't be he
probably did I'll give you that give you
that I I just thought Gerald was gonna
laugh and then he got no no I think I
doth protest too much
mr. sterling is a saint you know he's
you know you know she's here this
defensive when he busts out the English
quotes and the right
English accent that wasn't I didn't do
the English accent there I just what
about yellow
what about yellow tail or barefoot you
think I hope so because I don't want my
ride anymore
hey undercover operation to take them
out barefoot and yellowtail it's the
three-strike policy three strikes of
crappy wine okay here's another
democratic talking point right now I
don't know if you guys been following a
sweat room that Donald Trump in the GOP
that they are challenging efforts to
make voting easier right they want more
absentee voting and so this is a
narrative that people are hearing out
there there was a quote from Donald
Trump saying you know you look at what
they want it's ridiculous I don't think
any Republican would ever be elected
again they're saying see see with
increased voter turnout Republicans want
to suppress vote because they can never
win with increased voter turnout
why do you think let me ask this trick
question why do you think it is that
Republicans might have an issue with
simply opening up absentee voting
basically on a federal level superseding
states right now why do you think they
might have an issue with it do you think
it's just because they don't want people
legal American citizens voting from home
yeah that's totally it yeah it's got a
yeah I was shocked by the way because
Democrat you obviously know they're
against voter ID laws and they say
that's racist I was shocked as someone
who has had to vote absentee once before
that many states many states do not
require that you submit any form of
identification at all for receiving your
absentee ballot or when you submit the
actual voting ballot at no point is ID
required in many states I was going
through my kit going through the Alabama
Arkansas Alaska that's just the yeas he
aborted to the VA
yeah and in and what is it we have a by
the way the more that Democrats
obviously that can get a legals and
felons to vote the more they can
obviously sort of sell out the American
taxpayers I think in Colorado what is a
seventy three percent of people so
personally so that this was a note that
I put in there because the whole
argument yes it makes no sense my bad I
should put my initials in front of it
and change the color so basically what
they're 73 or egg fifty-nine wallet 65
in person so here kind of scribbling
you'd see on a serial killers wall with
strings of yarn and only I know what it
makes sense yeah so in a picture of
Phoebe Cape from Fast Times at Ridgemont
know so what they're saying is that in
November they don't want people to have
to actually go out and vote because it's
much safer to just mail it in and so
their whole argument is oh we have to
switch to this mail-in we already do it
with absentee voting why not well in
Colorado seventy three percent of the
people that got a mail-in ballot
returned it by hand and dropped it off
the same as if they had gone to a voting
location sixty fifty nine percent in
Oregon and sixty five in Washington
State from the studies that they were
using to cite to say that we should just
go to this because everybody's doing it
anyway it wouldn't solve the problem why
I would assume that they would resubmit
it anyway regardless at this point they
would probably send it back by mail I
don't mean said what the point he's made
is completely nonsensical there's no way
to decipher that from this point no I
knew that hollow 73 org for him they
were not for you until they were for me
there so it's kind of why there's the GM
right like if you're dyslexic and you
have to write them in Reverse with
jumbled letters if you're a serial
killer you write notes like this you
told me to have brevity with my notes
not in the way that I couldn't possibly
decipher what for you sir me what is
this the dark night comics are you
expecting Commissioner Gordon to come in
well no I like more of this I like more
surprise notes that Stephen
regarding states here's the thing to me
I actually I would have no problem with
absentee voting if it required some
proof of identification at some point
ideally both points ideally for you to
receive your ballot
you have to provide identification and
when you submit your ballot you have to
provide identification to left I mean
they want identification to purchase a
firearm to buy a big gulp to buy an SUV
to make sure that they know who has the
most carbon credits in need of purchase
not when somebody is electing the leader
of the free world yeah this is something
that is they try to oversimplify in a
way that makes very little sense and
here's one thing I will say too
sometimes of course from the left things
are so extreme where you go there's
there's no way that's true often it is
for example a lady drinking fish tank
cleaner because Donald Trump told her to
and her husband died you go there's no
way that's true well you're just saying
I want you to backtrack just like Legend
of Zelda Ocarina of Time like what
happened with the bees nests I have to
hit it with the silicon I don't have
this to go back and talk to the
villagers is a waste of time I hate
backtracking but you have to do it with
news don't get me started Majora's Mask
oh my god no that was just ridiculous
there's nothing a little clock tower -
shut up it stop it stop it stop with the
backtracking I want to I want a game to
play
not chores but you have to backtrack
sometimes it sounds so absurd there's no
way that can be true and often I would
say more often than not on the left
today
it is true but you should also backtrack
when you see the young turks or you see
John King oh you see looks like a Pixar
character who didn't make it you see one
of them story enough someone saying you
know what Donald Trump just doesn't he
said that no Republicans will ever win
if more people can vote you own a second
that sounds a little absurd why would
Donald Trump be against absentee voting
are we supposed to believe can use your
logic process here usually you use it
just a little bit we supposed to believe
it all of a sudden in the midwest and
texas and idaho people who are voting
from home because they have coronavirus
are going to swap to Biden that doesn't
make sense
no the reason that he has a problem with
it when you search it requires a little
bit of digging is that this is
ultimately a Trojan horse to try and
create new laws where you require no
identification to vote right you have
you require no identification to use an
emergency room sometimes they don't even
verify identification for social
services and now no ID to
and you wonder why the American taxpayer
thinks that you are selling them down
the river for people who have no
business being here who are not here
legally it's because of this this
shouldn't be a partisan issue no it's
it's your citizen so you can vote you
yeah and there a lot of the states that
they would win have large undocumented
populations like Texas and Arizona and
places like that that are closer to the
snow [ __ ] change it just gotta flip it
that you gotta flip one of those states
if you flip Texas it becomes almost
impossible for a Republican to win
consistently yeah they've got it they've
got to take a lot of other ground that's
very hard to take if you flip Texas like
that yeah and it's just lazy when you
think it's a lazy way to try and get
this mass voter bloc of illegal aliens
it's just let's allow absentee ballot
and then when Donald Trump says he's
against it will say that he just doesn't
like you know just like string some
string some taquitos or something along
into their life into the voting booth
and then maybe like you know like I
don't know just like could use a glue
stick and put on a fake ID yeah we'd at
least respect him okay all right maybe
you deserve to destroy our country from
within at this point by the way taquitos
are supposed to take it out of a corn
husk no tamale
it's like a little blanket it's like gum
man you can't eat it with the wrapper
but it comes with a paper wrapper over
the corn husk wrapper yeah it's just
multiple wrappers it doesn't make any
sense it's double right maybe one other
food that is double wrapped like that
one other Mexican enchiladas are not
double wrapped burritos are not double
wrapped actually burritos are double
wrap crap I just realized
idiot on here what made me something
else that is double wrap with an edible
form of wrapping paper come on I love I
love it just like keeps changing this
yeah it's like play-doh when you're a
kid when they sell you the play-doh fun
fact yeah it smells like a strawberry
yeah but don't eat it what do you expect
to do you just offered me a scrumptious
strawberry both visual sensory overload
since sensory overload how am I supposed
to know how this is gonna end up with
taste that's true till you taste it make
sense there it is and that's why I think
we need to make play-doh more toxic we
do have
going here soon
what was the other oh this is do we
check we can go to yes yeah so let's see
Jaden here says thanks for the month of
jacked up jacked up month of shows what
do you guys think we can expect from a
Biden Trump debate
good bad funny Oh funny I think it's
always going to be funny his Trump is
there time there was no Netflix special
though they are coming out with another
Joe exotic episode of other than that
there's nothing I'm more excited for
that Trump Biden it's good I think we
might see a fist fight and let me
explain you why let me give you this but
because you know Donald Trump did that
sort of that sort of uh yeah booming
behind Hillary Clinton she's horrible
that's kind of creepy right if he does
that behind Joe Biden first off he's
gonna get very scared you know like
Peter Pan has a shadow yeah and then he
probably SWAT and then Donald Trump will
probably SWAT back and then it'll just
be like Rock'em Sock'em old guys there's
gonna be hitting each other I wouldn't
be surprised because you were talking
about two very big egos oh yeah two very
very big egos one guy is already
president the other guy was vice
president feels entitled to it and is
crazy I mean you get Joe Biden he wants
to fight his own constituents to fight
he's not gonna Trump yeah let's take you
behind sound stage you want to talk to
me like that are you behind well God
said you're gonna have to leave me there
cuz I can't walk sure yeah
take me back don't be out there were you
sick crew who would you think would win
and if it's fight yeah well I will say
Donald Trump is a lot bigger but he's
listen as much and I think Donald Trump
has been a pretty good president he's
pretty gelatinous like let's be honest
yeah guys anything super physical you
can absorb the blows most even the
gelatinous it'll hero is laying around
Joe Joe Biden is um it depends I mean it
also comes down to fight IQ never who do
you think would win in a physical fight
between Joe Biden and Donald this is
actually interesting question so Donald
Trump obviously has the reach advantage
he obviously has the size advantage as
much larger does physically stronger and
Donald Trump has had a lot of
involvement with boxing and with mixed
martial arts
what so he's been a fan of the sport but
yeah it doesn't make him good at it
doesn't make him good at it but he's
been following it he's been on the
periphery for quite a while that's true
Joe Biden on the flip side is smaller
but he does seem to maintain his fitness
he claims that he box when he was a
young person but he also claimed that
you know heat at a nice diner which had
been closed for 34 years ago so I don't
know that let's assume they have no
combat history physical advantages
certainly to Donald Trump in size and
power as far as endurance probably Joe
Biden but here is sort of the outlier
crazy usually beats big every time and
so I don't you know just like Joe Biden
is actually an insane person you might
be like a crack head and you can take
more heat I think if someone on PCP you
know how they talk about being hit on
the button rightly retama this earlier
if you hit hit on the button is where
you actually get hit and it creates
enough vibration right there shot out of
the brain that rattles around but if
someone there buttons already been hit
but really just in a mental level in
other words they you it's not gonna show
up in a cat-scan
no I hit you right in the button and it
could be a you know could be a Tyler
Durden just you don't know you don't
know where I've been you have no idea
crazy beats big they're both a little
crazy but I think that Joe Biden is
clinically insane and that could play in
his favor
I think he's much more frail right now
to than Donald Trump and I think the
frailty part like he you you hit him
once if you just actually Donald Trump
all he has to do is step out of the way
dodged one blow and the guys going
face-first Donald Trump throw a perfect
leg kick the femur of Biden he's got
legs I mean I think he could throw a
good kick if you know like hey just go
by the huh what I stopped you stopped
because your tibia was snapped in half
you fool I think I think it's I think
Donald Trump has got to go with a circle
Joe till he gets out of his vision yeah
and then it's that moment perhaps he's
got an air he's got very low
you know peripheral vision and as soon
as he gets out of his vision Joe will
forget that he's in a fight know who the
ring the coaches are gonna be yeah I
tell you why to be great if just Donald
Trump brought out the black trainer from
the Rocky
it's all about looks without right and
joe biden's corner man would just be
like a hermit crab in a diet coke
handling on that note we do have to get
going so a couple of quick announcements
you're not announced tonight we are
going to be doing mass Monday talking
about rhett and Link for people who
haven't been mobile members we get into
a little bit of theology philosophy sort
of faith based discussion tomorrow
jeonggi Kambli is going to be live
streaming all of Duty's so live
streaming you guys requests it will be
live streaming and chatting with dehe
Dena Glo one of the biggest video gamers
on YouTube and I will say this to
Wednesday morning and good morning Mudd
Club the most offensive thing that we've
ever broadcast yeah ever in the history
of us Cal Graham it's upsetting and I I
don't I I seriously I don't say that
lightly Fox had pocalypse all of us
right now in this pandemic you just you
don't want a tune in Wednesday thank you
so much we appreciate it
it is mug Club quarantine the promo code
is quarantine $30 off we do appreciate
your support we'll see you tonight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I have the rose
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]